بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وبه نستعين
والعاقبه للمتقين من داخل قطاع غزه من ارض
الرباط جئتكم وزملائي محملين برساله محبه
واخاء وتضامن وتعاضد من دوله قطر قياده
وشعبا اقول لكم اننا واحرار العالم معكم
والانسانيه معكم والحق معكم والله جل في
علاه معكم فلا تهنوا ولا تحزنوا وانتم
الاعلون باذن الله وايم الله يا اهل غزه
لقد احييت الموات وايقظت انسانيه العالم
بعد سبات قبلكم كانت كل الكلمات جوفاء وكل
الحكايا مكرره وكل معاركنا اليوميه تافهه
وكل الخطابات والبيانات لا معنى لها كانت
الايام تتشابه طواحين من الماديات
والاستهلاكيه كانت تض
ضمائرنا وتحرق
ارواحنا ثم جاءت غزه لتعيد ترتيب اولويات
هذا العالم ولا ابالغ اذا قلت انكم اليوم
تعيدون لنا جميعا انسانيتنا التي سلبت او
ربما نسيناها فطوبى لكم واننا لنعلم حق
اليقين انكم اليوم وحدكم تدفعون هذا الثمن
ثمن فضح ازدواجيه المعايير ثمن كسر اله
الاحتلال المتغطرسه ثمن المنافح عن
المقدسات مقدسات مليارات من الناس من
المسلمين والمسيحين حول العالم لذا يا
اهلنا في غزه لست هنا في مقام التنظير
واستخلاص الدروس فانتم وحدكم اليوم من
تعلمنا بدمائكم الزكيه ودماء ابنائكم
الزكيه كيف تكون الحريه وكيف يكون الصمود
وكيف تكون الكرامه وكيف يكون الانسان اولا
لكنني جئت وزملائي اليوم لنقول اننا معكم
فلكم العتبه حتى ترضوا ولكم العتبه اذا
رضيتم ولكم العتب بعد الرضا حفظ الله غزه
وحفظ الله فلسطين والله غالب على امره
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون